the initial analysis that's been
conducted of the events that were
reported overnight is not consistent
with North Korean claims of a successful
hydrogen bomb test there's nothing
that's occurred in the last 24 hours
that has caused the United States
government to change our assessment of
North Korea's technical and military
capabilities now I hasten to add that
we're continuing so the work necessary
to learn more about the nuclear test
that North Korea conducted last night
but you've probably seen by now the
extensive independent analysis that's
been done in the United States and in
other countries that includes
significant in understandable skepticism
about the claims of the North Korean
skepticism of the claims of the North
Korean regime so you know we're
obviously going to continue to look at
this by monitoring the situation
assessing the available data and
evidence but the initial analysis is not
consistent with other claims the regime
has made of a successful hydrogen bomb
test this one